[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three
[Music]
all right hello good morning happy
thursday uh diablo mortal is out i think
some folks probably had the diablo
immortal on android or ios maybe
yesterday
but the pc version that's an open beta i
think for most folks not every region um
went live this morning
a little bit before 10 for me so we're
going to check it out
see what it's about
you know check out the new kind of like
wasde
uh movement that's in diablo
and been playing
you know the
the beta the alpha didn't get super
super far but um let's just do a little
question we can even try to see if we
can find a party
i saw a lot of folks on last night on
mobile um
and i see a bunch of people in town but
you know we'll see
we don't find a party here in a second
we'll just do it on our own
if you have questions of course uh hit
them up in the chat and i will do my
best to
answer them to the best of my ability
all right we're not waiting
so you can't control it
with just like left click like you
normally would
um
but it kind of makes sense why the
wazi's in there because like i guess
a mobile you can kind of like
be wary inside that tomb
the old kingdom hid many terrible
secrets
ones that prefer to remain hidden
secrets
buried in the sands
shrouded in darkness
many an adventurer
has attempted to retrieve the scepter
i don't need to explain what happened to
them do i
after all
the scepter
is still buried in the
sands uh all day long there is a
character creator sorry this is like my
mobile character that i started playing
last night that has the you know beauty
of cross progression
online
microtransactions
i mean the micro transactions are
definitely still uh on the pc version
like uh we'll see if it does that thing
where i think when you finish like a
dungeon like this it'll show you a
microtransaction um there's also like
the battle pass there's premium battle
pass there's like cosmetics um so that
part of it's like you know
very much here it's a free to play
oh we got a free reward um
it's a free-to-play game that's you know
got a bunch of microchips getting hit
which is awesome they're trying to show
the cats
microtransactions spiders um
so all of that is definitely
so like uh here's where you get the ozdy
right
because our mulder can essentially like
drag and
shoot at the same time you're a little
slower than normal but that's kind of
cool
yeah there is a as people mentioned
there is a character creation um
and there is some level of like
customization that you can do you know
there's you know uh
space like some different faces
and then like some
level of like you know skin color and
i think some other like various eye
shapes and things like that we can take
a look at that actually
and if you know some folks want me to
play something different just a show
instead of the demon hunter happy to do
that
i just happen to play some try something
different because
previously i played crusader i played
necro
i've played
monk even during early access monk has
some cool stuff which is interesting um
there's definitely some cool things that
i feel like they went
or lean didn't do because it was like
mobile like you could do like a jump
kick with the monk that would like
bounce off the wall and then come back
and then
also interestingly enough the uh
monk has
the dashing strike from diablo 3 except
it also does
um almost like cyclone strike in one so
i don't really know why they have cycle
strike and that because like i would
never take cycling
i will say though like if you end up
playing it on mobile it actually feels
pretty good pretty fine
what you would expect from the diablo
experience but like on your phone
um
and again uh it's open beta for most
regions so if you want to check out
you know check it out on pc
just go to your battlenet client and you
know find diablo immortal install it uh
i want to say it was like 20 something
gigs 25 26 gigs on pc
and then not sure how much the update
from this morning added to it i don't
think it was very much and then i think
mobile once you download all the
resources
and all the like
uh various maps and whatnot it was i
think almost like 12 to 13 gigs if i'm
not mistaken um
but yeah i also i think someone
mentioned controller i haven't actually
used a controller but i haven't plugged
in so we can maybe give that a go in a
little bit
and then i guess in in chat if people
really want to see the
character
creator or a different class or
something
obviously you know we start a new class
we just don't have as many skills off of
that but you know it's fun it kind of
comes
as you get them and then we can show
some different systems and things like
that
um
playing mobile for so long it's like i
don't know how to play npcs
how's level scaling in multiplayer if
any um that's a good question all day i
feel like yesterday oh sorry i truncated
your name there um i had like a level 30
something in
like a dungeon and i don't know if it's
scaled to
30. it felt fine i felt like multiplayer
made it like
too easy like i don't know if it like at
least in the dungeon like i don't i
don't know if it actually made it like
i don't know if it was harder because
there's more people i just feel like
we're just like doing big deep so
beginning could use some assistance and
i'm well again i don't know it was just
it's almost more efficient in a way if
you're if you're about like farming and
all that stuff
can you
trash talker yeah you know what i mean
yeah i guess i think it's better than
psp you got to admit uh yeah on your
phone you could do 60 fps if you want to
um
i think i'm on like ultra right now
though
let me see
we are on very high
so this is what it looks like at very
high
i mean
ultimately the way i look at it is like
you know there's a very low barrier of
entry yes there are definitely
um micro transactions in play and i
think you know i haven't done that much
research into it yet because i know that
there's definitely some some folks out
there that have
shared their
uh opinions on like you know how it's
basically you know there is gotcha
basically in this so
um
with the gems
systems because there's like level
like five star gems for legendary gems
and in order to get legendary gems
guaranteed you need a certain currency
of which i you get one in the beginning
of the game
um and then you don't really get them
that frequently you can you can still
farm legend or yeah farm legendary gems
through like rifts with crests but the
drop rates like really low so like if
you're really trying to min max
in this game like super like you know
for end game and whatnot there's
definitely going to be some micro
transaction stuff now
if you're playing
i think casually for fun and you're not
worried about minimaxing necessarily and
all that then i think
it's fine but also i just want to say
like my experience has been to like
level
40 maybe if
previously and i'm like 31 now so you
have to be determined from my end if
like how bad it gets because you know we
can open the shop and i can show you all
the different micro transactions those
beginners pack there's this is the
legendary crest i was talking about you
have to either pay 160 for one or buy 10
for 160. this lets you get into
uh kind of like level up your elder rift
which then with this legendary crest you
can i think guarantee a legendary gem
but you don't guarantee the star rating
so like i said there's star ratings one
to five
um there's bundles there's cosmetics
each of these are a thousand they look
cool but would i ever would i personally
ever buy them probably not i've
definitely seen people in game with them
and then there's also the like paid uh
battle pass but technically speaking
also as well you have um like your
normal
uh battle pass
so like
uh
you know there's different things you
can unlock there
and then you know as you're doing
quests and whatnot you you get different
things so like i don't know they
definitely incentivize you to do
different things there's bounties of
course
uh
can i not
that's weird
can they not scroll on this
okay well shows you how much i played on
on pc
usually you could just scroll through
for the the ring i just got but maybe
it's not
free nothing is free well that's not
true i'm
technically speaking the game is very
much free
apologies there's like a lawnmower
outside so i'm going to stop talking for
a
second
[Music]
the dead will not be the same
yeah it's me jake i am in the same boat
personally i have to say though that
i've always been a diablo fan so like
i can see why people could play this
right or want to it's kind of like when
diablo went out on switch sorry again
for the loud noise um and to define
mine's point yeah it's pay to win but i
like i said if you're not trying to min
max at least my perspective right now is
like if you're not trying to min max
then like i think it's fine you don't
have to engage in any of that stuff it's
when you really want to try to get into
the nitty-gritty and all that stuff that
that's going to be a pain for sure
probably
oh
every class has like this ultimate
builder up ability in the demon hunter
case it basically uses
i'm not ready yet
your fear betrays you
somebody asked why am i playing on pc
don't you guys have phones i mean yeah i
definitely played it on phone first i
think the reason why we're trying out pc
today just to show folks is
um pc veda is first time today i wanted
to see what the difference is there's
cross progression so you know i thought
that was cool i know
look i'm with everyone in the sense that
like they definitely did a poor job at
the
beginning
um
you know the whole you know plus yha
you know
but like the whole like you guys have
phones right that was not a great look
for them i think they know that
and candidly like when i first heard
diablo was going to come to mobile i was
kind of like
really that's not like
um
and maybe this is
just like i don't know like
i'll just be honest like i've got i'm
older now like i i have a child i don't
have as much time to just like
personally like play on the pc all the
time i like having the auction right but
like
you know doing a couple dungeons and
whatnot when i'm
you know on the couch or something like
that like
i don't know it works um and for the
people that are hating on it without
playing it like i think you should try
it
reserve judgment until you play
for the people that are telling me that
like it's not free
you you don't have to pay to play
you know there are definitely some
there's definitely microsoft
okay deny any of that there's definitely
some and some of the stuff i saw like if
that's really true with the the god kiss
stuff it's kind of like
five star gems are only like you know a
certain like you know only get them a
certain way etc that kind of doesn't
feel so great
yeah there's definitely some big bosses
i haven't done any of like the eight man
boss stuff i think
hopefully there's uh
i know that this kind of micro like
i hope if they do any micro transactions
in v4 that it's only cosmetic like i
don't care if they sell skins for all
like you know like if people want to
like look a certain way or look cool
that's fine i just don't want any
you know any advantages um
obviously
when you have a free-to-play game
they're gonna try to make money
sometimes
[Music]
so let me see um definitely saw
screenshots of folks that got like the
you know finish the dungeon and then got
like a um
you know hey buy this 99 cent chest from
this same dungeon um yeah it's in like
uh
it was announced like i don't know maybe
i have what i can this guy definitely
has uh micro transaction skip there's no
way
there's no way in hell he looks that
cool that soon um
but hey some people want to buy it right
some people want to spend the money
so separate that's telescopes
i i don't think i personally would buy
it you know but
for the people that want to buy it
and then a lot of the some of the good
quality of life stuff that you know the
three had like the orbs
um you know comboing like trying to keep
up with killstreak stuff that's in here
as well there's also like there's also
like auto navigate
um which is pretty nice uh for certain
certain quest lines and things like that
you could just like have it
auto run for you um
can't really i'm lazy so that's
definitely
that was yes the leader of the sand
scorpions
you sound like you're in a tunnel yeah
i mean
you know what can i do room's not
necessarily set up for the for the best
of things but
we're trying
we're trying i can also turn up the
gameplay audio if it helps but then i
think uh john luke was saying earlier
that that's the gameplay audio the light
is hidden in darkness
some place called the prison and then i
also wanted to click away from the boat
as well or get the mic away from away
from the keyboard because like if i was
deep you definitely hear everything
um
i don't need to check something
i actually don't have time to invest
with it so i'm not going to um
do people want to see the oh so here's
like battle pass right like here i'll
show you you can
play in your bounties level up your
battle pass
do various things you'll get you know uh
valencia you can just open up your
battlenet client
um just download find diablo immortal in
there and then just uh
i could get used to that you know just
just download it and play it it's open
beta there's only a few regions i think
that it's not available in so if it's
not there then that would be why but i
think in
most cases
it's out
i was i don't know we have a nice guy by
cameron koch and a beginner's guide if
you need it if people are playing and i
think he actually said to try to save
some of this for experience but whatever
we're doing it for the stream
um
we'll save some of those but so that's
the battle pass we're at level two now i
think technically
no that's in your pants
so i have one gem
um
i still don't understand
we need to go visit the identifier
are you gonna
navigate me
navigator
no all right
yeah
i still don't know which one's like
there's some that just let you get sent
and some or some that auto navigate you
and some that don't
i think another game that had good job
with cosmetics chitose is a path of
exile
yeah i mean i think cosmetics and arpg
sizeover assuming i'm saying your name
right is definitely gotta just be for
the money
need something reforged
the job well done
how may my knowledge that was quite the
find
use it well friend
you
[Music]
and what deal shall we make
never fall upon you
[Music]
so
i guess you get if you pre-registered
you get this kind of like cool skin for
free i guess
[Music]
this is the location on the map
but it is no prison
the entrance must still be concealed
so galileo
sorry if i've um
said your name wrong did you um
when you first signed up on mobile did
you end up um
tying it to your battlenet account
because if you didn't tie it to your
battlenet account the cross progression
wouldn't have worked so you probably
made a guest account on your mobile
whereas
you needed to make a tie it to your
battlenet account from the start for a
tap cross progression cosplay thing
energy
this
a light hidden in the darkness hmm
all that remains yeah i think you do
need to play on the same server
potentially too as well galileo uh
that's all i did i did like you said i
joined the same server and then i also
um
made sure my accounts were tied together
you've returned
you've returned
the scepter of fa
i can hardly believe it you may never
truly understand what you have done for
us this day
but know that we will be forever
grateful to you you have given me the
right to rule this land
the scepter is whole again
this moment will be remembered forever
[Music]
this legendary bow doesn't seem that
great
even though it's like supposed to do
homing
i'm just
like homie it's supposed to be basically
like shoot homing rockets but
seems okay now it is time for me to be
safe
this way friend we'll use the waypoint
to reach serieth quickly
our path leads by the sand scorpions
camp
so be wary
uh i like the game i mean
oops for me it's like too early to
really know though because you need to
see end game you need to see
really all the micro transactions and
stuff later if there's anything like
gatekeeping like everything so far early
seems like fine like i said like i don't
think you need to interact with any of
that microchip stuff no
i i don't know if it's like very mobile
though where
you know maybe you do everything you
need to do in a day potentially and then
like if you don't spend on buying some
currency or something like that are you
like out of things
in a day i believe
[Music]
no way to zoom out the camera um
i don't know
because like normally right like mouse
wheel
for um
on like d3 and stuff like that would be
how you like zoom in and out but like i
don't
i'm guessing it's because it's you know
matching
what's you know on mobile presumably so
[Music]
[Music]
you are marked for death
i get you bunny
easy
the library isn't far but
we've never been inside
there were too many warnings
it seems even the horadrim feared zoltan
cool's domain
if i believed in allow me to do
let the path be opened
uh revolt i imagine you should be okay
but you know we'll see
and kelvin makes a good point about
parody for pvp eventually
to make it as fair as possible
so yeah so now this is like that point
where like you hit level 35
and you're kind of out of like the main
quest things to do it is somewhat doable
but it's also harder right so we can go
do and check out some other things so
like um
i could show you a rift as well
uh revolt rivada i'm not 100 sure if
that spec matches but like you can
probably just look it up um and see if
that works or not because i think they
have specs on like high like high and
mid and low for what can run it probably
i mean yes george it's gonna look worse
than d3 because basically it's a mobile
game that's being like in a way ported
to pc right like they didn't originally
find well we don't know when they
planned to do the pc version but like
there wasn't plans prior it was supposed
to be mobile only right so
so this guy is the guy that sells the
legendary crest that i was talking about
you can still do
elder rips
um
and each day you do get a you do get a
daily
um crest so you get a rare one once a
day um which lets you kind of like do
this the rare quest
crests sorry have a like like a small
percentage chance to give you like
a legendary gem but it's very like low
which is why a lot of people are saying
this is kind of scammy
um and not so great but um
we'll do just we'll just go through this
elder riff just you can see what it
looks like it's very much like a d3
elder riff or a rift rather
and then there's also challenge rifts
which we could also do right after this
so we'll hop into this one real quick
so here's the like negative to it acidic
[Applause]
ah
vengeance
you gotta remember this is not this is
tp right on a phone
that's much smaller in your hand it's
it's definitely um
a little crisper but it's not going to
be like
amazing necessarily so
i mean
i think most mobile games aren't
necessarily that like
graphically beautiful something with the
point
funny you mentioned uh torchlight kelvin
because i think they they also have a
like mobile airplane
oh i am healed
it's like
oh man i want to say it's like
torchlight xd yeah
don't have enough energy
do
so
[Music]
[Applause]
and if anyone's cares uh for later today
sony does have a say to play
uh i think it's psvr and they're two and
third party stuff if i'm not mistaken if
that's what if i recall the blog saying
so that's at 3 pm pacific which is
roughly three hours from now you want to
come back hang out check out what uh
sony's got up from their
roster i guess a
third party and psdr2 games come back
for that
and thanks everyone for tuning in
you deserve nothing less
i'm not ready yet
okay so that was a rift
you get crafting materials i think for
trying to make gems
salvage some stuff
most appreciate what can i do for you
all right let me
get back to town the job well done
good to see you're still alive yeah i'm
still alive
still kicking kicking and screaming i
guess
foreign
um actually robert there is
uh
one skill that is different
for sure
let me pull that up we can use it if you
want to check it out let me see what we
give up
so daring swing that is definitely not
in um
d3
pick everything else might be though
maybe escape
yeah so darren swings like uh let's see
so you know
so
does it support controller yes it does i
actually have a controller plugged in
but i've never
played on the controller i can try to
give it a go
uh we try to find a party oh let's go
there's a 11 44. let's see what happens
this is not diablo 4 by any means word
789 this is diablo mortal originally
and still
meant for mobile first but they they
ended up doing kind of like a pc port
that's in open beta
um that people can play and one person
of course
did not want to go in echo who's level
all right
44.
i'm gonna see if these folks want to try
to do a party so you can see what that
looks like
although
no idea how to i've never used the
daring
swing uh
skill so no idea how good that is
necessarily but we'll give it a go and
see what happens
so we are currently in a challenge rift
level two
with
two other
strangers
yeah the party uh i will say party on
live right now at least you know since
it's like launch day so i can day two
depending on how you look at it is
pretty good
um
there's only been a handful of things
that i
so then we got a necro and a barb in our
group
i actually haven't seen these types yet
so i don't know
only in like the second area presumably
i guess
you cannot
where's our other buddy oh no there's a
rare minion over here
cool
i mean gaming lazanne
sure you know nobody has to play
anything they don't want to right
like for like all i can say is hey you
can try it if you want if you think you
want to play diablo on another phone
if you don't
all good right like you don't need to do
that
vengeance will be mine but if you're
interested you want to try it you can
download it free
if you don't like it uninstall if you
don't even want to do that don't even do
that
how can you play on your pc um just open
up your battlenet client
and then also look for diablo immortal
then just download it um
and you should be able to play
outside of a few handful of regions
but otherwise anyone should be able to
you know hold on i didn't say anyone
most people should then be able to uh
to play
that was a challenge rift that we joined
you know just some a party with
uh and then i can show you the um
the whoop bounty board
although i think we might need to finish
our bounties
i shouldn't have done that
should have waited till we finished all
four but it's fine
i guess you can only have four at a time
and right now i have access to eight in
the in the day i think
um
so we can go let me go do the bounties
real quick
just show something different but we'll
try to go finish the ones in like the
first act or whatever
lorenzo yeah there's there's definitely
some pay to i think pay to win or
definitely pay to speed up
um i i personally don't know enough
about the like end game and like i've
only watched a couple videos in terms of
how like the legendary like
gems work and how there's like you know
rank one to five kind of like with
gotcha game stuff
um
like engine etc uh and i know that that
is tied to a currency that you are
either very limited in getting i think
there's definitely one that you get in
the beginning that they try to introduce
you to with
and then after that it becomes really
hard to get that currency
so again i think how i prefaced it in
the beginning is if you think you just
want to play fun you're not worried
about mid maxing you're not worried
about like the most optimal and the most
damage etc you're probably gonna be fine
without paying for anything um
however you know if you're trying to
like really min max and like you know
really
play end game maybe pvp etc then you
know i think that
that's when some of that stuff come into
play and be really
kind of annoying
this happened to me earlier today too on
this specific quest where like
i there's just no enemies to kill
but everything else seemed fine so far
so i don't
it's kind of frustrating to be honest
we can try to go to this one but this
one kind of was kind of fork too maybe
i'll have to just get rid of these two
and just do nothing but the
second section area
i mean like i don't know if
i don't know if just because that they
didn't spend time and resources making
this game gaming was on that you know d4
would be out sooner maybe i don't know
this was probably always in the works
regardless and like i don't know
candidly like
it will probably be very successful
right like even if people don't want to
admit that there are probably a lot of
mobile gamers out there there's a lot of
you know the people they call whales who
are going to spend money on this game um
ultimately and i think there's an
audience for it you know would i like to
have d4 sooner of course i'd love to
have d4 sooner um
but you know
i don't know if like not making this
game would have necessarily changed that
i guess
um
how do you do it i've nearly struck
there's not all right does this change
anything here no
this so this happened to this quest too
where like it sends me here
and then literally there's nothing to
kill
so i don't know if this is just like a
bug it's bounty or not but um
we might just have to uh
can i even get rid of it
yeah so those are our free cosmetics
then you can buy the rest if you wanted
to
i'm gonna see if i can get rid of those
other two um
quests that aren't really working or
bounties uh looks like diablo 3 doesn't
have the same classes it has similar
classes
there's the demon hunter
barbarian necromancer sorceress wizard
monk and crusader
i think i got them all um and then for
the most part the skills are
more or less the same outside like a
handful
that i've seen so far um but there is
some skills that are different can i not
i guess i just can't get rid of them huh
all right well we'll just go do these
real quick
yeah so like kelvin alexander bring up
kind of similar point that like it's
probably
you know this this was in development
regardless probably doesn't necessarily
impact
d4's release right like you know they
definitely had a team for this and i
don't think that team necessarily just
because they uh
weren't risks or whatever would have
necessarily
i mean but who knows right like i don't
have that insight actually from the
developers themselves but i'm pretty
sure they would never say
that was the case
and i don't know like i said
i have to openly be honest and say i
played diablo since diablo one two
you know three all you know expansions
resurrected etc
and so
you know i actually
as much as i thought i didn't
ever or that i thought i wasn't going to
play a mobile version of diablo like
actually
deep pretty fun decent you know
especially if you're not you're just
trying to play like a little bit playing
a rpg on your phone
like
i don't know but again i i
like diablo in general so it's easier
for me just to be like yeah of course i
played that on mobile right
uh
okay i finished that one
let's see where's the other one
naked
so another auto navigate which is nice
that way i can just
chat with chat
no
what's up song toast
where are these wolves i need 23 more of
them
[Music]
i was just telling some of my uh
co-workers how like
i i swore the density
much better
on live than it was um
during the mini early access type thing
but maybe it's just more folks are
playing too and killing all like there
was definitely a barbarian also killing
wolves and probably this guy
also killing wolves so
we're all fighting for the
same
bounty which is kind of
but i think if you like walk away from
the area and then come back like does a
pretty good job just like respawning
those i might just have to kill this
like three wolves over and over
oh there's a better time has come
okay everyone wanted to
kill that
one i wonder why i didn't do it with
bart
i think he's doing the same thing
which maybe he is maybe he's not
sorry about that y'all
yeah see like these three keep coming
back pretty quickly so you just kind of
have to like hover in this area it's
also why i have a century over there to
like tag them
oh wait did we finish it
yeah we did
uh these what both better
sure
this is a hard pass from ninja gabe
that's all right like i said don't have
to play
um
you know if you want to play mobile with
your friends significant other et cetera
like just hop on your phone and do that
like i said if you don't even want to
play it don't do it go play d3 um you
know or play um d2
or
d2 remastered or
path of exile
play whatever you want really right
the beauty of games
folks can enjoy what they want to enjoy
all right let's get these other ones
we'll do these other two
and then
i can check out character creator stuff
if people want to see that i don't know
okay
okay just doesn't want to walk me
a glorious chest
all right
got a belt though
probably an upgraded
oh yeah they tell you they give you like
recommended goals
so mine is probably not very good
i'm missing that i'm missing one of the
abilities okay okay
okay
yeah you can i don't know
i'm with you calvin it's like one of
those things where you could like easily
play like
maybe do a couple bounties or something
call today if that's enough if not then
i go the wrong way i feel like
oh you're gonna lose sound for a second
all right
getting the mobile experience on pc
seems like a big step down though yeah
i mean i don't know for me the only
thing that goes that's like a positive
at all when i first heard that they were
doing i was like oh at least it has
cross play cross progression if i ever
want to play on pc then i'll do that but
chances are for me i'd probably just be
playing on
on
mobile anyways probably oh my god really
there's no way right that there's one
bandit that you'd kill over and over
oh thank you
yeah they need to figure this out
because this is this is not so good
and i have to try to scam it with uh
with my sentries
oh
i am
did we finish it
nope
now we need to kill 30 more
oh i should have joined that guy huh
okay he's done
i need more time
i'm almost there
it's just uh push the button for the win
game no the the boss stuff you gotta
move around
um
okay
oh
i am well again
where are the monsters
sure
uh
this is not so great
the monetization is a joke go watch as
mongol
what level is he at millie i haven't
been able to really watch any of the
other folks playing it but there's that
like i said there's definitely some
stuff that like if you're trying to mim
max et cetera we're trying to just like
unlock more legendary gems and whatnot
like
it's it's kind of rough wait what is
oh
this
that exit uh i can show you the micro
transactions after we or the
the shop so to speak after we get
through this this quest or not quest
bounty but this bounty might take a
second because uh
there ain't no demons to kill
and we need 50 more
um
which is weird because
some of these areas were like so heavily
populated before i don't know if it's
just because
other people are here or what but
uh
outside of that little pocket of little
demons that i killed just now there's
like nothing
i mean i don't i don't plan on spending
a i refuse
i think
looks worse than gotcha games really
like i know that i know the legendary
gems is pretty bad because there's like
one to five stars so
um
yeah that doesn't sound so great though
for sure
i don't know what to do here other than
maybe try to go back in that little
corner where there was a actual monsters
and just keep killing the same batch
over and over i guess
i don't even think that i wonder if
that's actually faster than walking
holy smokes okay you know what else we
can try to do we could try to exit and
come back in
maybe we'll get a different like
instance thing
did we do it
no
no red dots
that's kind of annoying
all right well i can show you the job
so there's featured you could buy battle
pass stuff
either 4.99 for this or 14.99 for the
collector's version
there's the boon of plenty so these are
those legendary um
crests that i was talking about that
help you get the legendary gems but
doesn't guarantee that you'll get a five
star or anything like that i think it's
just like getting a gem
um
and there's like way more stuff after
that too i think there's like something
called like resonance that i haven't
even checked out or anything like that
but that cost
could cost some some money
this is the hundred dollars
um which i think somebody was breaking
down like if you had a hundred and
you're trying to buy like
like how many would you actually get
like was that seventy two hundred
don't do the math sixteen hundred thirty
two 64.
you get like 45 or something like that
and then there's like this beginner's
pack i i don't even want to click on
anything you get one daily reward for
free um
is this game pay to win i
it could be later i don't know at this
at this level talia
um there's definitely some stuff that
like
could stop you from like mini maxing i
think you could probably play the whole
game
free to play
but you know
ah this
respond sooner than the
maybe
i don't know this this is this uh what's
up chronic trigger from london thank you
for joining
this is uh
annoying
does it feel better on pc than mobile uh
it's different
gene john sorry for butchering um
i think i'd
probably rather play on mobile
i'm pretty sure you could level
without that stuff still but like i
don't know how fast so if someone hey
ron if somebody actually did the math on
that that's kind of bonkers but
zitro did you have to like
do you feel like you needed that battle
pass or did you just do it to do it i
just wanted the skins okay yeah like i
think you could level
without any of that stuff but
i it's like a speed thing right like
with every other mobile game out there
it's like you're just accelerating
i don't know again i don't
unless you're like thinking about going
hardcore like i don't really think that
microtransactions will
affect you as long as you have your own
good conscience to be like no i'm not
paying for that i'm not buying it in
cases they will throw it in your face
like on mobile they definitely put like
like hey buy the battle pass like when i
logged in and like
i don't know so there's definitely some
of that all right you know what we're
just going to do some riffs because this
this
this quest this bounty is like kind of
like whatever i'm not streaming it from
my phone mr solo i'm playing the pc
uh open beta which has cross progression
from your um
from your phone now if i wanted to
stream from my phone i could try to do
that um it's a little harder for me
because i have a pixel 6
pixel 6 does not like to like hdmi out
from a usbc
so
i would essentially have to like
chromecast it and if you thought these
graphics didn't look good that would be
probably
worse and if i could show you i would
but i don't have the chromecast
apologies
also what's annoying is i've already
clicked on the recommended builds thing
but yet it still wants to tell me the
recommended builds
what are you going to do
we'll say i don't remember seeing these
little uh like
skeleton
uh
there's a new minion
heal me
i am renewed
what is this what does it draw
i'm playing this over arvs that don't
have micro transactions uh the draw
would be that i mean
from uh from the actual like mobile
perspective it's like that you could
play on mobile
right whereas some of these arpgs aren't
on mobile so
it's like that's what
the draw is i guess you know outside of
you know having the diabolo name
obviously so you know there's people
that
myself included that i played a lot of
diablo in their their lifetime so
they're like oh cool diablo
immortals free on phone freon well for
now three on pc from you know
from the beta
i think it's just more that it's you
know having a mobile diablo now if you
already have like d3 for switch and
you're playing that once already like
you're probably not
as much of a reason to play like
immortal on
phone outside of maybe just experiencing
something slightly different
i am healed
you can see the york if you want
to buy that
don't have anything
and like you know surprisingly it is
like plays
pretty decent
if you didn't have like a switch and you
didn't have diablo on the go this would
be like diablo on the go i suppose
what do you mean the first time i beat a
challenge i've done that already
also why would they give me a shrine
after or whatever
um i will probably do like one more
challenge rift or something and then
probably call it a stream but i really
appreciate everyone coming out hanging
out so like any
last minute questions etc like fire them
off i'll try to
answer them to the best of my ability
here we can try finding a party
definitely already level 40s out there
so
it's only been out really a day on phone
mobile if you think about it so people
are definitely leveling i don't know how
many of these folks are interacting with
micro transactions but i think we had
someone in the chat just now say like
they
did buy the battle pass but at 42 so
they got the 42 without it
yeah rinstacio this is the pc version
and thanks so soon for answering so here
we go we got four person party for their
talent trip
oh somebody wanted to ask about scaling
they are definitely stronger here
you are
i'm injured oh i'm gonna die yeah
yeah
first dad
okay uh did he also survive ready
all right so the the person that asked
if there's a scaling there's definitely
some level because these guys are way
harder
um with four people
and you can see like they're like out of
they have like the exclamation mark on
them so they're definitely like
five plus levels uh higher than me
which makes this very uh inefficient to
say the least
i don't know why i would do that
presumably you think that they want to
try to keep people closer together
maybe they view it as like oh
as a group it
it'd be
fine that i came
dude there's like
i am the lowest i guess
can't even hide in the back
whales will praise the game
i mean hey like i said i think it's fine
if you're just playing casually you're
not thinking about the micro
transactions too hard and you're not
trying to like mid max for that like
later part if you are
probably gets a bit rough probably not
worth it
um
but if you just want to like
play and chill and
whatnot not worry too much about it but
i think it's fine like i've gotten with
the 33 now without really
i haven't spent anything so
you know
when will the game be playable like it's
full on pc i don't know all they've done
is announce this um
open
uh beta which most people i guess i
should join and try
um you know ultimately it was
focused for um
well i mean technically speaking we got
the rip card right now
[Music]
and then she does some like bullet hell
stuff
so like oh my lord the bats
how
okay i
i want the chat to give me a replay did
i actually get hit by that back because
i swear my character did not look like
it was like next to it but i got i got
got so i'm guessing i did get hit
so yeah definitely scales a bit
um the stuff is above my level
good job to my team for putting me in
their backpack
because
i feel like i didn't do very much there
um
you know mainly because of i think the
level difference obviously
yeah i think mailer to your point
honestly like
i think folks just have to play it right
and try it and if you're if there's
folks worried about the the monetization
of the predatory stuff just you know do
your due diligence
check it out try to like watch some
folks that are putting out good videos
um in terms of like
what to expect
i'm sure we'll try to do some type of
micro transaction type breakdown
um you know
if we can on game sponsors is just like
what the currencies are what to watch
out for
um i think we have like a
you know how to play for free type
article up and then we also have like a
beginner's guide so if you wanna
check that out be uh check that out you
know uh but i really appreciate everyone
kind of coming out hanging out uh asking
questions chatting
again like i said we'll be live again in
about two and a half hours for the state
of play uh sony state of play i think
it's psvr2 stuff as well as third party
stuff hopefully there's some cool things
um
but yeah that's diablo mortal we'll have
a review
hopefully maybe in the the coming week
weeks maybe depending because i think uh
we wanted to make sure the review was
starting from you know
day one so they probably started getting
going maybe yesterday today so it could
be a little bit depending on how we get
along there but
um can you disable the on-screen mobile
controls
uh i think there's different types of
control settings that you can you can
get into
um
i think or there's more on mobile i
think um and then there's like
controller stuff that i didn't get to do
but i have one plugged in but anyways
thanks so much
have a great day everyone stay safe
um happy thursday
i will go off in just a little bit
you